señor néstor quisiera preguntarle lo
siguiente como prevee que puedan quise
hacer los vínculos de carlos tercero con
américa latina' no quizás sobre todo en
materia medioambiental en este momento
en el que todos los países están quizás
tratando de mancomunar sus esfuerzos
contra la crisis climática
entiendo
fue mi percepción
tenía y tiene un gran aprecio por
américa latina e hizo varios viajes a
colombia y méjico
a chile en fin
yo creo que tiene un gran interés por el
tema yo espero que las delegaciones de
américa latina que deben venir al más
alto nivel a los funerales de la reina y
tengan una representación a niveles de
jefes de estado y ministros de
relaciones exteriores que puedan ser una
oportunidad para para renovar y mantener
esos esos nexos el reino unido tiene un
nexo muy importante con américa latina'
y aquí hemos tratado de mantener y de
revivir una política real
y yo diría que en los últimos diez años
ha habido un renuevo del acercamiento
del reino unido a la américa latina
lógicamente hoy día en esta crisis que
vivimos
la necesidad que tiene el reino unido-
de contar con una diversidad de socios
es muy importante el éxito como en sus
etapas de
desarrollo y de consolidación necesita
una diversidad de
países que trabajen con el reino unido
que importen que exporten que inviertan
y yo creo que es una tarea de gobierno
que está en que está en desarrollo